zone europe / sensations
[Musique]
bon
oh là bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour
ce nouveau numéro de zone europe / radio
sensations et tv 78 une émission
spéciale réalisée à barcelone en espagne
dans cette émission il sera largement
question de tourisme mais également du
programme erasmus plus et pour cause
l'espagne accueille chaque année plus de
80 millions de touristes étrangers et
c'est la première destination erasmus
mais tout d'abord je vous emmène au
centre à l'eas à barcelone où de jeunes
enfants handicapés peuvent suivre des
stages intensifs de kiné et de nouveaux
réhabilitation
sous groupe map et stéphane guillon je
suis à maman de nathan et la présidente
d'association n'attendent combat d'un
ange nathan il est atteint de la
mutation du gène atp 6 v 1 à aujourd'hui
il y a à peu près 20 cas dans le monde
enfin contre s'il a une mutation qui est
assez forte au niveau de son handicap
enfin l'handicap de des enfants qui sont
atteints de cette maladie
dépend de la du degré de mutation du
gène et là effectivement on attend à un
degré qui est assez important puisque
aujourd'hui il est pieds petits qui ne
marche pas ils ne parlent pas il a des
troubles autistiques
ça fait depuis juillet 2013 convient à
barcelone pour platon face à ces
thérapies on vient ici parce que parce
que déjà nathan connaît bien les
thérapeutes donc il est en confiance
avec les a et samuel
c'est quand même 3 4h de thérapie par
jour donc on va dire c'est comme de la
kiné mais intensive ou nathan apprend à
à stabiliser son corps à se muscler à
tenir assis à tenir à quatre pattes
tenir debout
voilà tout ça c'est pour le renforcer
musculairement pour pouvoir justement
arriver à ce qu'ils tiennent debout
debout tout seul quand même marché bon
avec nat 1 c'est pas on a on a commencé
à retravailler un convoi qu'est ce que
c'était les a pris au niveau des bras
gagne un peu plus de stabilité au niveau
des omoplates bien sûr on a bien regardé
à niveau de dos comme si tout allait
bien et un niveau de bassens et y est de
lui donner un peu plus de stabilité on
travaille beaucoup des baux aussi pour
essayer de l'intrus des forces et plus
de conscience au niveau des jambes au
niveau des extrémités pour qu'elles
puissent aussi nous aider aussi à la vie
quotidienne avant et né juste assis
maintenant il tient à quatre pattes
debout avec appui avant il avait le
bassin qui ne vacille à de gauche et à
droite maintenant il a réussi à
stabiliser son bassin et puis à côté de
ça à côté du fait que faisait thérapie
il aime bien être ici pour lui c'est
vraiment un moment de plaisir même si
c'est rêver dans l'effort il apprécie
beaucoup un attend comme toujours
il est trop près des câlins et les liens
aussi être prochain nous ça n'a pas
changé après c'est vrai qu'on l'a trouvé
très très très grand il a grandi
énormément et ça ça veut dire que si des
informations que il aurait soin de son
corps et sauce aussi différents
non maintenant parce qu'il a pris
beaucoup de taille mais quand même c'est
vrai qu'il est super disponible à
travailler et vraiment c'est c'est
agréable on est très content de revoir
nous on essaie de les donner les maximum
d'informations possibles au niveau
corporel on essaie d'arriver au max de
ses capacités avec eux est vraiment
finalement c'est eux qui font toutes les
tailles non mais on essaie de les
accompagner dans cette
schéma pas arrivés au maximum de
capacité possible pour eux je suis avec
les halos monaco robles bonjour alors
vous avez créé le centre de neuro
réhabilitation à les associe à barcelone
vous êtes diplômé en neurosciences et en
kinésithérapie notamment alors tout
d'abord pourquoi est ce que vous avez
voulu créer ce centre bah en fait je
trajet j'ai étudié kiné en 2013 j'ai
fini ma carrière et j'ai commencé à
bosser avec des enfants est bon ça a été
ma passion découverte du coup bah je me
suis dit pourquoi pas offrir ce que je
sais aux enfants et après c'est comme
une petite drogue en fait quand tu
commences à travailler avec les enfants
tu peux plus t'en sortir de là les
enfants que vous accueillez ici ils sont
de tout âge tout âge ont le plus ancien
qu'on a eu c'est un monsieur de 65 ans
avec un avc en fait on travaille avec
moi je dirais qu'avec tous patients
neurologiques alors on voit qu'il ya
beaucoup de parents français qui
emmènent leurs enfants pour faire des
stages intensifs ici pourquoi est-ce qu'
ils viennent ici c'est parce qu'il n'ya
pas de structures similaires ailleurs je
pense parce que
le nombre d'heures caen caen propose et
l'intensité et le rythme il à répétition
font des résultats simplement et
actuellement il ya d'autres centres
aussi en espagne il ya d'autres centraux
pologne il ya plusieurs centres je pense
que là la kinésithérapie intensifs et
commence à bouger un peu dans tous les
sens mais
c'est vrai que actuellement en france
ils proposent pas forcément ça et du
coup je pense que c'est ce qu'ils
cherchent les parents n'ont qu est ce
que ces enfants peuvent faire dans deux
trois mois soit fait dans une semaine il
y ait des résultats un peu plus vite
vous parlez de kinésithérapie intensive
qu'elle sait quoi comme type d'exercice
qu'on fait avec ces deux là qui n'est
nommé normal on va dire la clinique
comme moi j'ai appris à travailler que
de comprendre le corps humain comme une
fois avec une fonction globale tuera pas
uniquement le genou qui fléchit en
extension ni par extension sinon comment
le jeu luis relaciones avec les autres
parties du corps ça c'est le plus
important pour les enfants et je pense
que c'est le plus important aussi pour
qu'ils se connaissent à eux mêmes tu
vois moi j'ai toujours dit que quand tu
ne bouges le monde debout le moule bout
le mouvement pardon est le plus
important pour pour vivre du coup quand
que toi tu apprends enfants à bouger il
ya rentrer en relation avec son corps
tout le reste après suis et c'est
difficile c'est difficile pour les
enfants de de faire ce geste je dirais
pas que c'est difficile c'est nouveau et
tout ce que ces nouveaux des fois c'est
sortir de sa zone de confort et sortir
de son confort des fois ça fait peur et
je pense qu'il ya l'émotionnel en fait
quand tu travailles ans avec le corps
humain tu travaille aussi avec les
émotions et avec le community c'est pour
ça que beaucoup de parents ils nous
disent boire mais il sera la sienne
autrement avec son environnement et son
ratio notre moi avec lui-même et avec
nous même nom et deux fois ils sont un
peu plus indépendants au des fois ils
recherchent des étapes intérieur toi
c'est une toute une nouvelle découverte
justement quel lien est ce que vous
entretenez avec avec les familles des
patients vous les suivez vous leur
donnez peut-être des conseils aussi pour
travailler à la maison oui on donne tout
le temps des conseils normalement fait
un bilan en fin de semaine où on
préconise tous les exercices qu'on
devrait
continuer à travailler sur mon autre
manière de voir l'enfant et surtout nous
on aime bien garder le contact on a
toujours dit qu'elle est à c'était une
petite famille du coup on aime bien
qu'on compte sur facebook on les suit au
sur les apparents des fois ils nous
envoient des petites vidéos il ya des
fois on dit obama essaye cette méthode
là pour lui faire avancer mieux la jambe
au des petites astuces pour continuer à
progresser vous fait un peu partie de la
famille oui
et le but pour le centre à l'avenir
c'est quoi aider plus de plus en plus
d'enfants de plus en plus de personnes
de tout âge agrandir le centre bas
actuellement c'est un peu difficile à
dire c'est vrai quand on est en train de
regarder pour éventuellement
pouvoir proposer un et structure un peu
plus grande peut-être mais à niveau 2
2 si tu veut agrandir l'équipe c'est
encore un peu difficile pour nous ça on
est un petit cocon on aime bien on
s'entend bien ça m'allait - s'entend
très bien on s'entend bien avec les
familles tout est très fluide du coût
intègre une autre personne c'est une
autre dynamique et c'est un truc à
réfléchir aussi très bien merci beaucoup
léa d'avoir été avec nous pour en savoir
plus sur le centre votre page facebook
et le site aléas bcn points comme exact
merci beaucoup merci
sous drop
je vous parlais de tourisme tout à
l'heure l'espagne accueille plus de 80
millions de touristes par an c'est un
gros enjeu économique ont fait un bref
retour à paris avec ferran tarradellas
espuny c'est le chef de la communication
de la représentation de la commission
européenne
en france il nous parle du développement
touristique en espagne
[Musique]
vous voyez en espagne la seule loi qui
était approuvé à l'unanimité dans le
parlement espagnol en ligue 2 se dire
tout le monde c'était justement l'entrée
à l'union européenne l'année 1986 parce
que pour nous entrés dans l'union
européenne ce et est entrée dans le club
des nations civilisées c'est un peu le
dire comme ça on venait de sortir de la
dictature du général franco
et l'espagne pendant toute cette période
c'est de quarante longues années il
faisait pas partie de continent européen
est envoyé avec beaucoup de jalousie
c'est ce que l'europe était pour les
français les hollandais les italiens des
allemands etc et il avait un grain à vis
de la part de tous les espagnols pour
faire face de sept clubs et un moment
qu'on est rentré voilà on a dit
finalement on est retourné chez nous
dans notre continent leur nous
appartenons c'était très important pour
les espagnols évidemment pour ce très
important s'il a reçu deux sont des
structures elle probablement dans des
pays qui est mieux profiter de fonds
structurels et de cet exercice de
solidarité européenne qui est finalement
c'est ce fonds européenne c'est
l'espagne qui compte à rendre l union
européenne il avait
[Musique]
grand père capital d'environ
85% de la moyenne européenne et que
l'année 2008 était à la moyenne
européenne c'est-à-dire que quand on
était là on a fait un grand
avancé grâce à ses formes les secteurs
de l'agriculture a bénéficié aussi
beaucoup de
fonds de la pac on a eu d'effet le
manque d'infrastructures qui aurait été
pas possible ça c'est l'intervention
européenne et surtout le business
espagnols etc y compris le tourisme mais
pas qu'eux ont pu rentrer dans le marché
unique avec beaucoup beaucoup plus de
facilités pour faire du business et
l'espagne en fait c'est un pays qui
exporte beaucoup dans le marché unique
est fière de ma chronique grâce au
traité de libre commerce que l'on fait
avec des pays tiers il faut dire par
exemple à condition qu'ils étaient venus
apprécier en espagne mariko début
c'était un peu de confusion c'était
l'euro et la possibilité de voix là où
il est j'y vais pour tous les continents
avec la possibilité de ne pas voir
d'échanger des monnaies chaque fois
qu'on traverse un pays finalement pour
maintenir une chose mais la liste
pourrait être beaucoup plus longue
l'espagne et les premiers pays
récepteurs des étudiants erasmus est le
premier pays exportateur on peut dire
d'étudiants erasmus de l'union
européenne se montre appliqué comme pays
c'est un pays attractif pro européen
pour faire ses études merci la vie des
espagnols raconterai d'autres européenne
dans les autres pays et l omnium
[Musique]
bon le secteur touristique doit faire
les changements que toute l'économie
européenne doit faire il faut faire la
transformation digitale et la
transformation écologique il faut dire
que dans le domaine on a eu de très
fortes avancées
on voit maintenant dans les autres
espagnols mais aussi dans d autres
attractions touristiques qu' il y ait
cette sensibilité pour travailler par
exemple avec
des jardineries avec les espèces locales
qu'on essaye de réduire les plastiques
au maximum connaissait de réutiliser
l'eau que nous sert appliquer des
critères d'économie circulaire à la
façon comme comme on gère les
infrastructures touristiques on voit
aussi qu'il y a un grand effort pour la
digitalisation pour l'utilisation de
technologies digitales dans ce secteur
pour faire les réservations de voyages
hôtels l'étiquette pour les attractions
touristiques
pour les matchs de foot servir pour
toutes et tous sur deux secteurs voilà
en avançant dans sept des priorités
de la commission
1 européenne évidemment il reste encore
beaucoup de choses à faire il faut que
qui luttent contre les nationalités un
des problèmes du secteur touristique
c'est que pendant les mois d'hiver comme
il n'ya pas de touristes il est beaucoup
de travailleurs qui perd son travail
alors voilà il faudra faire peut-être
dans des programmes pour lutter contre
l'insécurité du secteur touristique mais
voilà la théorie mais se passer du
secteur de l'espagne peut-être ce serait
intéressant de rappeler que l'espagne
est le deuxième producteur de voitures
en europe après l'allemagne et c'est
possible et justement parce que beaucoup
de sociétés européennes se sont
installés en espagne y compris des
sociétés françaises comme citroën
renault et que voilà les produits qui
ont fait en espagne peut être exportée
au marché intérieur me suis au pays
tiers à travers des infrastructures
portuaires que la un peu partout en
espagne
sous drop
l'espagne est la première destination
des jeunes européens qui partent étudier
dans le cadre du programme erasmus plus
rencontre à barcelone je m'appelle tome
j'ai 21 ans je viens de finir mon école
de commerce donc bac +3 et là je suis en
master 1 actuellement à l'université de
barcelone en échange erasmus
[Musique]
tout simplement parce qu'on vient de se
faire deux ans pandémie et que c'était
c'était assez compliqué mais surtout
parce que je voulais vraiment renouveler
l'expérience que j'avais eu du coup
lormont première erasmus en suède qui
est de rencontrer des internationaux
pour ma part je parle que anglais
français italien et du coup je me suis
dit pourquoi pas partir apprendre une
nouvelle langue et puis c'était aussi
l'occasion de pouvoir voir un nouveau
système éducatif qui est pas forcément
le même qu'en france qui a plus de
flexibilité sur certains sujets et
encore une fois de me faire des amis en
quatre coins du monde parce que
aujourd'hui j'ai gardé pas mal de potes
de suède et c'est vrai que pour
l'instant c'est des potes mais à terme
pour le monde professionnel on va dire
ça à constituer un réseau quatre coins
du monde et du coup quand on voyage
c'est super pratique
[Musique]
mais déjà la langue ici je suis en train
d'apprendre l'espagnol parce que je
parlais vraiment rien rien rien et
d'être immergé tout le temps de parler
avec des locaux c'est vrai que ça m'aide
énormément du coup pour le commerce que
j'étudie c'est sûr que c'est intéressant
et puis au delà de ça ce que ça m'a
appris c'est surtout d'arriver à casser
mes préjugés d'avoir vraiment une
ouverture sur le monde ça c'est super
important on s'en rend vraiment pas
content en fait quand on est en france
on se dit ouais on va faire un erasmus
et des lacs ans c'est trop bien mais est
ce qu'on nous dit pas aussi c'est toute
la pression qui a dans le erasmus que
c'est censé être la meilleure année
notre vie et du coup on culpabilise
presque quand on sort pas ou qu'on dit
non à quelque chose on a énormément de
pression et c'est pas toujours tout beau
il ya nos parents qui nous manque nos
familles qui nous manque et des moments
où on se sent exclue on n'a pas
forcément nos amis au début et c'est
quelque chose qui peut être assez dur
donc ça m'a appris je pense aussi à
avoir ses dettes cette adaptabilité et
cette capacité à me dire que toute façon
je suis le seul sur le terrain qui peut
m'aider qui peut régler les problèmes
que jeu auquel je vais faire face donc
du coup ça m'apprend à me débrouiller
sam apprend à grandir et je me sens un
peu plus chez moi dans plusieurs lieux
du monde c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui si
je retourne en suède je sais comment
fonctionne le système administratif les
transports ce genre de choses donc c'est
un petit peu comme si j'allais en france
quoi
[Musique]
le quotidien barcelone ça ressemble a
pas beaucoup de sens vraiment pas
beaucoup moi par exemple j'ai cours cinq
jours par semaine donc le matin j'ai les
cours à la fac et ensuite j'ai des cours
d'espagnol et puis sinon généralement il
ya beaucoup beaucoup d'assaut étudiantes
notamment ce qui s'appelle le sn erasmus
tunac network qui est une association
pour spéciale pour les erasmus qui
organise beaucoup d'événements donc
c'est vrai qu'on sort pas mal on
rencontre beaucoup d'internationaux et
puis les week-ends il ya aussi des
lectures des excursions qui sont
organisés donc on va pouvoir visiter les
alentours de barcelone des fois on se
repose mais c'est vrai que c'est assez
intensif comme rythme
[Musique]
je conseille à 100% parce que je pense
que ça n'a aucun rapport avec ce qu'on
pense que c'est il faut vraiment le
vivre notamment pour la partie qui est
difficile qui pour moi est la partie la
plus importante parce que c'est ça qui
fait qu'on grandit et qu'on va élargir
notre zone de confort et que demain si
on est amené à voyager ou amiens se
retrouve dans une situation qui pourrait
paraître incontrôlable difficile on va
se sentir beaucoup plus à l'aise pour
appréhender ce genre de choses et puis
même au niveau de l'ouverture d'esprit
c'est un truc de malade parce qu'on est
à barcelone donc avec des espagnols mais
aussi avec des internationaux donc ça
peut être des personnes qui vont venir
du brésil ou d'asie et du coup c'est
vraiment un choc culturel énorme et on
apprend beaucoup de ça et du coup on
peut s'inspirer des cultures des autres
et comprendre moi personnellement depuis
que je suis ici et je suis pas rentré en
france depuis deux mois je vois la
france comme un étranger alors qu'avant
je voyais la france comme un français et
maintenant je comprends pourquoi les
étrangers isadore paris trouve que tout
est trop beau l'architecturé etc parce
que je jeu en parlant avec eux je vois à
travers leur regard comment ils
perçoivent la culture
sous drop
[Musique]
bon
on va parler business à présent dans une
europe car j'ai rendez vous avec
christian marion c'est le directeur de
la cci france espagne christian marion
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes le
directeur de la cci la chambre de
commerce et de l'industrie france
espagne vous regroupé plus d'une
centaine d'entreprises des entreprises
françaises mais implantée ici quel type
d'entreprise on trouve ici enfin on
regroupe 450 entreprises
françaises et espagnoles tous secteurs
confondus alors la première chose la
particularité c'est effectivement c'est
50 50 on à 50% entreprises françaises
donc des des filiales implantées ici est
également des entreprises espagnoles de
barcelone par exemple qui ont soit des
filiales en france soit qui
s'intéressent au marché français donc du
coup c'est un club assez multi
culturelle multilingue
d'entrée leurs membres en fait oui et
quel est le rôle de la cci avec ces
entreprises il ya deux rôles en fait les
chambres de gaz française à l'étranger
c'est avant tout c c'est une association
ces associations d'entrepreneurs et
c'est une certaine façon c'est chasser
en meute s'est essayé de faire en sorte
que ont
animé un club un club d'affaires et les
aider d'une certaine façon à avoir plus
de visibilité leur donner les bons les
bons conseils su me rentrer secteur des
feuilles de 500 activités entre
différentes activités au sein du maine
entreprises de différents métiers et
finalement d'une certaine façon avoir
des fins partager beaucoup
d'informations entre entre les
entreprises donc assez la partie club et
une partie également prestation dans
laquelle on est des entreprises
françaises à venir s'implanter mais
également les voeux les entreprises
espagnoles à partir vers vers l'espagne
tonnes va donc à il ya deux il ya deux
activités la partie club et la partie
prestataire de services en lettres et
les missions vous réalisé avec les
entreprises c'est les mêmes avec toutes
les entreprises où il ya des entreprises
qui ont besoin des deux plus spécifiques
dont il ya des entreprises qui ont
besoin finalement 2-2 déjà de savoir si
s'il ya un marché ici un marché si le
marché peut répondre alors ses excuses à
une place sur le marché si leurs voix
sur leurs services et leurs produits
ont leur ont leur place en espagne donc
du coup c'est vraiment des études de
marché et après il est entre autres des
entreprises qui cherchent vraiment à
s'implanter bon du coup ça c'est de
l'implantation pur et dur la création de
la filiale création
les mettre en contact avec eux avec les
bonnes personnes pour pouvoir embaucher
pour pouvoir créer la structure
juridique
et
après il ya les services qui sont déjà
ici est effectivement à leurs besoins
c'est comme vous ou au début c'est
plutôt mieux que mieux communiquer mieux
vendre
avoir des bons contacts entre perd donc
vous tel en totale entreprises et chez
nous est ce que vous pouvez me faire une
intro et de membres et membres en fait
c'est ce genre de connexion qui marche
très très bien au sein d'un club en fait
et qu'est ce que les entreprises
françaises peuvent apporter ici en
espagne qu'est ce que le secteur peut
être qui fonctionne le mieux alors cinq
ici à barcelone c'est une c'est une
ville qui est très cosmopolite qui a
tiré depuis quelques années énormément
notre présent la technologie
donc beaucoup beaucoup de startups
françaises qui viennent s'implanter
barcelone soit parce que le marché
répond favorablement c'est un peu le
premier marché auquel on pense juste
après avoir
avoir fait ses devoirs en france c'est
essayons un marché qui est proche qui
est similaire au marché français mais
c'est aussi une porte d'entrée pour pour
le reste
l'amérique latine par exemple et c'est
également un endroit où il ya beaucoup
de talents du talent peut-être un peu
plus abordables qu'en france ou même que
qu'en région parisienne et donc du coup
les entreprises françaises qui viennent
souvent ici parce qu'il ya énormément de
français qui ont choisi barcelone comme
comme on est en droit de vie et ses
ordonnances et entreprises se sentent se
sentent à l'aise ici on a un petit
écosystème comparé par exemple à une
ville comme londres ou une ville comme
paris mais très bien connecté avec
beaucoup d'universités beaucoup
d'entreprises locales beaucoup de
startups local d aide et d aider des
associations comme la nôtre mais même
d'autres locale qui aide vraiment à
s'implanter et donc du coup c'est assez
simple en fait de faire venir des
entreprises et qu'elles réussissent leur
leur business ici à barcelone en fait
vous conseilleriez à des français de
venir ici faire du business oui bien sûr
c'est c'est c'est un bel endroit c'est
par exemple il ya une souvent une
question qui se pose lorsqu'une
entreprise française n'arrive pas à voir
c'est pourquoi on trouvait dans la tête
par exemple qui n'arrive pas avoir
forcément du talent où on n'arrive pas à
attirer suffisamment de talent le talent
devient très cher surtout dans des
technologies très très compliqué
certaines ont simplement décidé de venir
à barcelone pour attirer mieux c'est ces
personnes en leur disant écoutez bon bah
c'est sympa par email a en fait on a
ouvert aussi une filiale à barcelone et
sa complète en fait pas mal le package
d'attractivité le fait de devenir
devenir barcelone pouvoir être près de
la mer et de la montagne dans une ville
qui est assez sympa dans laquelle on
mange bien et comme je vous disais très
très bien connecté avec beaucoup
beaucoup d'entreprises en fait dit tout
à l'heure vous avez aussi les
entreprises espagnoles à venir
s'implanter en france vous faites ça de
quelle manière alors soit on les en les
connectant avec des partenaires
commerciaux en france par exemple savent
se mettre de la recherche de
distributeurs de la recherche de
d'agents commerciaux soit en leur
conseillant de s'implanter
les aide vraiment à créer la filiale à
paris en france justement on conseille
pas que paris c'est un rôle aussi de
leur dire allez allez quand ils viennent
vous voir ils vous disent on aimerait
s'implanter à paris souvent souvent
c'est vrai une demande et
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué besoin
d'importer jusqu'à mars et c'est un
marché qui est très concurrentiel mais
c'est pas la seule porte d'entrée en
fait on leur colle on leur conseille à
la limite même de jouer la proximité
pour tester le marché français est peu à
peu de deux appareils après ça j'ai
pensé c'est une boîte plus traditionnels
industriel ça marche si c'est une boîte
plus technologique effectivement la
place de paris tan tan dung listed
investisseurs que d'accès au talent est
vraiment conseilla bhl mai sinon lors
leur fait voir qu'il ya quand même
d'autres d'autres d'autres zones de
france qui sont également intéressantes
pour eux donc soit on les aide vraiment
à rechercher des partenaires soit on les
avait vraiment à créer créer une
structure juridique pour qu'elles
puissent directement au lent même à
chercher des chercher des candidats
cherchent et du talent même des français
qui sont déjà ici et qui s'intéresse à
des boîtes espagnols etc les premiers
candidats pour venir en france sera pas
pour aller en france de la main d'une
beauté ce management et dernière
question si vous aviez un conseil à
donner un entrepreneur français qui
aimeraient venir ici s'installer à
barcelone là je vous ai dit qu'il était
très facile que personne c'est bien
c'est simple le premier conseil c'est
quand même essayer de voir que c'est
quand même un marché qui est différent
c'est un marché qui est qui et qui est
proche c'est un marché qui est qui et
pas aussi exotiques que d'autres marchés
mondiaux mais il ya toujours des astuces
et donc du coup ne pas arriver en
territoire conquis souvent les français
pendant des années ont été perçu ici
comme voilà plutôt des conquistadors
jean ça marche en france de marché en
espagne évidemment voilà un peu plus de
voix la recherche à plus de
questionnements avant de se lancer la
limite on peut me servir à ça pour les
pour les conseiller et faire en sorte
que la queue que la proche soit sur le
plus facile possible merci beaucoup
question mariant d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et je rappelle que vous êtes
le directeur de la chambre de commerce
et d'industrie france espagne
zone europe / sensations
[Musique]
fond
il
on pouvait naturellement pas venir faire
une émission ici à barcelone sans venir
voir la sagrada familia sa construction
a commencé en 1882 et elle n'est
toujours pas terminée zone europe en
revanche c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission un
podcast audio et vidéo sur notre site et
notre application radio sensations bonne
soirée à toutes et à tous à la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
sous une robe sûr sensation
zone europe avec le soutien financier de
la région ile de france